>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Amy Stolls: We ready?
Good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> Amy Stolls: This is exciting.
Here we are starting the day of
the National Book Festival here
in Washington, D.C. Welcome.
Welcome especially to those of
you who are new, relatively new
to Washington, D.C. I'm Amy Stolls.
I'm the Director of Literature at
the National Endowment for the Arts,
and it's my distinct pleasure to
open the National Book Festival
by featuring our Poetry Out
Loud winners from this year
and our distinguished judge from
this year, and poet, Adrian Matejka.
Before we do that, I'm going
to there's a couple
things I want to say.
That all day here at the Library
of Congress National Book Festival,
we're recognizing and
celebrating the importance
of reading and authors and book.
And the Library of Congress makes it
seem so easy to do this every year.
But the truth is, the National Book
Festival is a huge undertaking,
and it is a huge financial
undertaking.
And it's been made possible by
generous support from our sponsors.
The National Endowment
for the Arts is one.
You can see who they are in your
programs and on the video monitors
around the Convention Center.
But we can't take for granted that
this event will continue to exist.
So I'd like to ask you to consider
making a contribution using your
cell phone.
You can send a text to make a
one-time gift that will be added
to your mobile phone bill.
And it the details are on screen
and on the back of your program.
And so now, on to the main event.
The National Endowment for the Arts
Literature Program supports reading
and books and authors across
the country in many ways.
We give direct grants to poets
and writers and translators.
We give grants to organizations,
like publishers and literary centers
and service organizations
and book festivals like this
to do what they do too
encourage people to read.
We also have a program
called the NEA Big Read,
which is a community read program.
We give grants to 75
communities around the country.
And we have a program called
Poetry Out Loud, which we're going
to feature today and you're
going to hear all about.
You can find out more
information about our programs.
In the back at the table we
have a whole bunch of pamphlets
and our wonderful staff back there.
Hi, staff.
[Laughs] All right.
Before we-- I'm going to
turn it over to Eleanor,
who has been managing the Poetry
Out Loud program for a long time.
I want to take a moment
to acknowledge our
National Student Poets
who were just recently named
and it's very exciting.
And it's always exciting
when we have young poets,
like Poetry Out Loud and our
National Student Poets going
around the country as ambassadors of
poetry, because they're passionate
about poetry and they're
good at what they do.
The President's Committee on
the Arts and the Humanities,
the Institute of Museum and
Library Sciences, and the Alliance
for Young Artists and
Writers partner
to present the National
Student Poets Program,
the country's highest honor
for youth poets presenting
original work.
So five outstanding high school
poets whose work exhibits
exceptional creativity and
dedication to their craft
and promise are selected
annually for a year of service
as National Poetry Ambassadors, much
like our Poetry Out Loud folks are.
So I really want to
acknowledge the five
who just recently won
this distinguished award.
And I'm going to say this
names and ask them to stand
up and so we can applaud.
Representing the Southeast,
Annie Castillo.
[applause] Representing
the West, Kinsale Hueston.
the Midwest, Ben Lee.
[applause] Representing the
Northeast, Juliet Lubwama.
[applause] And representing the
Southwest, Camila Sanmiguel.
Round of applause for
all of them, please.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I had the pleasure of
listening to them yesterday
and reciting their poems
and was incredibly moved
and inspired that this
is our future.
In the same way that
when I went to the finals
and I know Adrian can speak
to this too, as can Eleanor,
and everybody in the audience,
that when you hear these
poets recite poetry,
whether it's their own or
others, it makes you really,
really hopeful for our future.
And that they can do all sorts of
things and have dedicated a portion
of their lives to poetry.
So with that, I'm going to turn
it over to Eleanor Billington
to tell you about Poetry Out
Loud and to introduce Adrian.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Eleanor Billington:
Hey, everybody.
Good morning.
So welcome to the festival.
Amy already welcomed you,
but I want to do it again.
It's really a wonderful event.
We are so happy you're
here with us this morning.
On behalf of everybody at the
NEA, thank you for being here.
So as Amy said, my name
is Eleanor Billington.
I've been helping to manage
Poetry Out Loud for many years,
and it is quite a wonderful job.
I'm very, very lucky.
So I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the program.
I'm going to do that first and then
introduce the guests on the stage.
And then I'll get out of the way
and they're going to do their thing,
which is going to be great.
So Poetry Out Loud is a national
youth arts program that seeks
to foster a new generation of
literary readers and engage citizens
by capitalizing on
recent trends in poetry.
And those are recitation
and performance.
So Poetry Out Loud encourages high
school students to learn classic
and contemporary poems
through memorization
and then public recitation.
So this was started as a partnership
back in 2005 between the NEA
and our great partnership, The
Poetry Foundation, and 53 state
and jurisdictional arts
agencies across the country,
which means that the Poetry Out
Loud program is in every state,
D.C. The U.S. Virgin
Islands, and Puerto Rico.
Since the program began, we have
had 3.3 million students participate
and over 50,000 teachers
across the country.
The program helps students
build public speaking skills
and self-confidence,
but most importantly,
it really helps them discover
their own creative voice.
I say this every year
at the book festival,
but I say it because it's
important for us to acknowledge.
And for many people, and I was
included in this group actually,
before I started to
work on the program.
Poetry recitation can sound
a little bit dry, right?
But you're going to see in a couple
minutes firsthand, that the power
of a poem spoken aloud
is real and it's moving.
And these students are
absolutely phenomenal.
So how does the program work?
It's a pyramid structure.
It's a lot like the spelling bee.
The students start at the
classroom level and then they move
on to a school-wide competition,
and then they may have a regional
or a state finals competition.
And then they finally come to
D.C. to the national finals,
which are held here every spring.
If you are an interested high
school student in the audience
or an interested high school
teacher, there is still time
to sign up for this year.
So if you want to find out
more or want to get in touch
with your state arts agency
that's hosting the competition
in your state, you can go to the
table in the back, like Amy said,
where our staff members are, and
find out more about the program.
So you can get involved this year.
It is not too late to get involved.
We have a great website that's
dedicated to Poetry Out Loud.
It's poetryoutloud.org and on the
website there are over 900 poems
that are eligible for recitation.
There's a great teacher's guide.
There are tips for reciting.
There are great video examples.
Actually, most of the students
on the stage are featured
in videos online.
So you can find out a lot
more about the program there.
Again, everything in the
back table about POL is free
and everything online is free too.
Last year, we had more than 315,000
students participate in Poetry
Out Loud, and today you're going to
hear from three of those students,
three state champions who made
it all the way to the top nine
at the 2017 Poetry Out
Loud National Finals.
Poetry Out Loud students are
eligible for prizes at the state
and national level,
including a $20,000 prize
for the national champion.
Every year, Poetry Out Loud
awards more than $100,000
in prizes and school stipends.
So a $20,000 prize is
nothing to scoff at.
It's incredible, especially
for a poetry recitation, right?
But we believe that the real
reward for us as administrators
of this program, but
also for the students,
is when they connect very deeply
with the poems that they memorize.
In a recent conversation
with the Iowa Review,
our new U.S. poet laureate Tracy
K. Smith describes one of the first
and most important relationships
she had with a memorized poem.
She says this.
"In one of my fifth grade textbooks,
there was an Emily Dickenson
poem titled 'I'm Nobody!
Who are you?'
I inadvertently memorized it.
It almost felt like the
speaker and I were in collusion
with one another, like there was
this amazing space the speaker had
invited me into.
I liked that sense
of private mischief
that poetry seemed to
be able to extend."
This morning, we extend
an invitation to you
to enjoy what these poems will
bring to your own life experience.
We invite you to listen differently
and to embrace the mystery
and mischief of language, and
we ask that you honor the work
of these students as they
share their perspectives
and talents with you.
Before we begin, I'm going to
tell you a little bit about all
of our guests and our moderator.
So Iree Mann.
Iree, do you mind waving?
[laughs] Iree is the 2017 Poetry Out
Loud state champion from New York.
She's a senior at Syosset
High School in Long Island,
and she is here with
her mom and her teacher.
She's very involved in the African
American Club and is captain
of interpretive events on her
school's speech and debate team.
Iree wants to pursue acting as a
career and she enjoys writing plays
and sharing her own stories with
a limited audience right now.
She said just her dogs.
[laughter] So she's working up
to a broader audience, right?
[laughter] Nick Amador.
Nick? Is a 2017 --
is our 2017 Poetry
Out Loud second place national
finalist, and he's a senior
at Punahou High School in Hawaii.
He is passionate about
theatre, stories,
and combating climate change.
In his free time, he writes poetry,
watches Game of Thrones,
and plays with his dogs.
So we have a canine theme.
[laughter] We also are so happy
to welcome the 2017 Georgia state
champion, who is also our Poetry
Out Loud national champion
for this year, Samara Huggins.
Samara's a freshman at
Pratt Institute in New York.
She is studying fashion
design there.
In addition to designing,
she is a writer
and a supporter of
all things creative.
She's also going to be featured
at the international
storytelling festival
in Jonesborough, Tennessee
next month.
Finally, we are very, very pleased
and honored to be joined by poet
and Poetry Out Loud national
finals judge, Adrian Matejka.
Adrian is going to lead today's
discussion with our students.
He is the author of
four books of poetry.
His third book of poems,
"The Big Smoke,"
about prize fighter Jack
Johnson, was a finalist
for the National Book Award
and the Pulitzer Prize.
His most recent collection, "Map to
the Stars," explores the tensions
between geography, race, and poverty
in America during the
Reagan era in the '80s.
You can hear more from Adrian
about his new book right
here in this room at 1:00pm.
[laughter] But now, we're going
to talk about Poetry Out Loud.
So he's a champion for the program.
We are so honored and just delighted
to have him here this morning.
You guys are going to really
enjoy their discussion.
So that is more than enough from me.
It is time to turn everything
over to Adrian and the students.
Thank you guys again for being
here and enjoy listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Adrian Matejka: Thank
you for that, Eleanor.
I'm going to sit down because I
got rained on, and you'll notice
that my pants are all
soaked if I stand up, right?
[laughter] But I'm so glad to be
here, and I don't know where Amy is,
but thank you, Amy, for that too.
I've been really fortunate to
work with Poetry Out Loud for,
I don't know, maybe eight years?
I started out as a local judge in
St. Louis and got to spend time
with the program that way.
And then I become a regional judge,
and then last year I was
fortunate enough to hear all three
of the amazing performers on stage
right now last April as they --
I mean, you're going to hear it.
So I thought that what we
might do to start out with,
because this is a program about
poetry and about recitation
and about inhibiting
a kind of art in a way
that makes it publicly
accessible, I thought the best way
to begin would be to allow
them to recite a poem for you.
And so then you'll see it,
and then we can talk about it
after you get a better sense.
Iree do you want to start and
then we'll just go across.
>> Iree Mann: Sure.
Hi, guys. [laughter]
"The Golden Shovel"
by Terrance Hayes.
After Gwendolyn Brooks.
I. 1981. When I am so small
Da's sock covers my arm,
we cruise at twilight until we
find the place the real men lean,
bloodshot and translucent with cool.
His smile is a gold-plated
incantation as we drift by women
on bar stools, with nothing left
in them but approachlessness.
This is a school I do not know yet.
But the cue sticks mean we are
rubbed by light, smooth as wood,
the lurk of smoke thinned to song.
We won't be out late.
Standing in the middle
of the streets last night
we watched the moonlit lawns
and a neighbor strike
his son in the face.
A shadow knocked straight.
Da promised to leave me everything:
the shovel we used to bury the dog,
the words he loved to
sing, his rusted pistol,
his squeaky Bible, his sin.
The boy's sneakers
were light on the road.
We watched him run to us
looking wounded and thin.
He'd been caught lying or
drinking his father's gin.
He'd been defending his
ma, trying to be a man.
We stood in the road, and
my father talked about jazz,
how sometimes a tune
is born of outrage.
By June the boy would
be locked upstate.
That night we got down
on our knees in my room.
If I should die before I wake.
Da said to me, it will be too soon.
II. 1991 Into the tented city we go,
weakened by the fire's
ethereal afterglow.
Born lost and cooler than heartache.
What we know is what we know.
The left hand severed and
schooled by cleverness.
A plate of weekdays cooking.
The hour lurking in the afterglow.
A late night chant.
Into the city we go.
Close your eyes and strike a blow.
Light can be straightened
by its shadow.
What we break is what we hold.
A singular blue note.
An outcry singed exiting the throat.
We push until we thin, thinking
we won't creep back again.
While God licks his kin, we
sing until our blood is jazz,
we swing from June to June.
We sweat to keep from weeping.
Groomed on a diet of
hunger, we end too soon.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Adrian Matejka:
That's really wonderful.
And the poem that Iree just
recited, "The Golden Shovel,"
is based on a poem by
Gwendolyn Brooks too.
So the end of each line is a word
from Gwendolyn Brooks'
poem "We Real Cool."
It's a really wonderful
kind of take on form,
and then also just a beautiful poem.
I really want to ask you about that,
but I know we have this
little bit of time.
[laughter] So it's a whole
conversation I'd love
to have around these poems.
But let's -- thank you for that.
Nick, would you like to go?
>> Nick Amador: Yeah, absolutely.
"Lions" by Sandra McPherson.
Lions don't need your help.
In the Serengeti, for instance,
one thousand like the very rich hold
sway over more than Connecticut.
The mane of the lion, like the
hooked jaw of the male salmon,
acts as a shield for defense and
is the gift of sexual selection.
His eyes are fathomless amber.
The lion is the most
social of the big cats.
Pride members are affectionate
among themselves.
They rub cheeks when they meet.
They rest and hunt together.
And cubs suckle indiscriminately.
But strangers or members
of a neighboring pride
are not usually accepted.
If a pride male meets a
strange female he may greet her
in a friendly fashion
and even mate with her,
but the pride females
will drive her off.
Male lions, usually depicted
as indolent freeloaders
who let the lionesses do all the
hunting, are not mere parasites.
They maintain the integrity
of the territory.
Lions eat communally but
completely lack table manners.
Indeed, lions give the impression
that their evolution toward a
social existence is incomplete,
that cooperation in
achieving a task does not
yet include the equal
division of the spoils.
More bad news: lions
are not good parents.
But prowess, that they have.
Their courage comes
from being built,
like an automobile, for power.
A visible lion is usually a safe
lion, but one should never feel safe
because almost always there
is something one can't see.
Given protection and power a
lion does not need to be clever.
Now, lions are not
the most likable kind
of animal unless you are
a certain type of person.
That is, not necessarily leonine
in the sense of manly or ferocious,
but one who wouldn't mind resting
twenty of twenty-four hours a day
and who is not beyond
stealing someone else's kill
about half the time.
Lions are not my favorite kind
of animal, gazelles seem nicer,
[laughter] A zebra has his
own sort of appealing pathos,
especially when he is
sure prey for the lion.
Lions have little to
offer the spirit.
If we made of ourselves
parks and placed the lion
in the constituent he most
resembled, he would be in our blood.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Adrian Matejka: A visible
lion is usually a safe lion?
Is that the line?
[laughter] I'm going
to take that with me.
[laughter] I think it's wonderful
to have "The Golden Shovel,"
and then Sandra McPherson's poem
one after another to see the range,
not only of poetry in
its own, but also the way
in which these young performers
have taken advantage of the kind
of tone of poetry to share.
It's really great.
Thank you for that.
Samara, would you like to go ahead?
>> Samara Huggins: "The
Farmer" by W.D. Ehrhart.
Each day I go into the
fields to see what is growing
and what remains to be done.
It is always the same
thing: nothing is growing,
everything needs to be done.
Plow, harrow, disc, water,
pray till my bones ache
and hands rub blood-raw
with honest labor.
All that grows is the slow
intransigent intensity of need.
I have sown my seed on soil
guaranteed by poverty to fail.
But I don't complain,
except to passersby
who ask me why I work
such barren earth.
They would not understand me if I
stooped to lift a rock and hold it
like a child, or laughed,
or told them it is their
poverty I labor to relieve.
For them, I complain.
A farmer of dreams
knows how to pretend.
A farmer of dreams knows
what it means to be patient.
Each day I go into the fields.
[ Applause ]
>> Adrian Matejka:
[laughing] Oh, that's so good.
Thank you for that,
all three of you.
So "A farmer of dreams
knows how to pretend."
What a wonderful metaphor.
Can you talk a little bit about
how you selected that poem,
and then maybe we could
spin this in.
I know there's 900 poems
you can choose from.
So maybe talk a little bit about
what drew you to that to start
out with, because that's important.
>> Samara Huggins: "The Farmer"
was the last poem that I choose,
because for the competition, each
student has to have three poems.
So I chose "Novel" by Arthur
Rimbaud, "Dream Song 14"
by John Berryman, and
then "The Farmer."
And I needed a different tone.
I had a youthful conversational
tone with "Novel."
And more sarcastic and cynical
tone with Berryman's poem.
So I wanted something that
was a little bit deeper,
a little bit darker.
And this poem is about
perseverance and struggles.
>> Adrian Matejka: And it
feels very timely too, right?
I think one of the great gifts of
poetry is it can be timeless, right?
It's the kind of that you could
-- if it was written in 1800,
it could still matter now because
those basic things, need and want
and love, they sort
of transcend, right?
The trick is figuring out how to
offer that message to someone.
Did you read poems before
you started in this program?
Or was this something that the
program kind of get you going?
>> Samara Huggins: Did
I read them out loud?
>> Adrian Matejka:
Well, just in general.
Where you a fan of
poetry to start out?
>> Samara Huggins: Oh, I was.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah?
>> Samara Huggins: Yeah.
I read poetry a little bit.
>> Adrian Matejka: See,
this is the thing, right?
You know, I'm just going to confess
now that when I was in high school,
I was busy doing everything
possible not to read.
[laughter] So when I spend
time with people who are
so much more sophisticated than I
was, I just think, wait a minute?
You knew about po-- I didn't
even find out about poetry
until high school,
but I thought poetry
and rap music were the same thing.
[laughter] So then probably
since you came into it that way,
since you already knew
about poems, is there a--
has the program, working in this
program at all changed the way
that you imagine a
poem to work or to be?
>> Samara Huggins: It has.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
How so?
>> Samara Huggins: Now I know
that poetry is really alive.
You know, you hear your
English teachers tell you
that literature is timeless and
poetry lives and all this stuff.
And it sounds like it makes
sense, but I didn't believe it
until I started in Poetry Out Loud
and until I made the
poem come alive.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah,
that's really wonderful.
What about you, Nick?
Had you been reading poems
before this or was this something
that you came to through
Poetry Out Loud?
>> Nick Amador: Yeah.
I-- I don't know.
Poetry was never a huge part of
my life until Poetry Out Loud.
I'm an actor, so I had
done a lot of theatre.
And I think part of the reason that
I started with Poetry Out Loud is
because I love being in front
of people and I love talking.
[laughter] So I think that is why
I got involved in Poetry Out Loud.
But poems are like
friends, you know?
You have to spend time
with them in order
to realize not only what they
mean, but what they mean to you
as an individual and how you
can try your best to do justice
to that message and make sure
that other people understand
what it means to you
through the way that you speak it.
So Poetry Out Loud has
allowed me to understand poems
in a completely different way.
I have a totally changed
and improved appreciation
for what poetry is.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
And you get to come to D.C.
>> Nick Amador: And I get to come
to D.C. [laughter] It's far away.
>> Adrian Matejka: It's really far.
I think you-- this was your second
year in the finals group too,
or the regional group, right?
>> Nick Amador: Yes.
Yeah. So this past spring
was-- I won second place,
and that was the second time
that I had made it to nationals.
The year before, I
had won third place.
>> Wow.
>> Adrian Matejka:
Yeah, it's always--
so I got the opportunity to
hear Nick two years in a row
and he was wonderful both times.
It's not surprising that the
process of articulating poetry
or reciting poetry would speak
to you as a theatre major too.
Because some poems are
just monologues, right?
So you have the opportunity-- the
best poetry, and I think all three
of you display this -- communicates
and it shares a kind of thing
in the truest sense, right?
There's poems that require
digging in and learning and reading
and re-reading, but for me, the
greatest poems offer themselves up.
And we can assist in that
in some way as readers.
Iree, did you read
poetry before this
or was this a new thing for you?
>> Iree Mann: This
was a very new thing.
[laughter] I have never really gone
into poetry before,
even in high school.
I've never read a poem
and gone into it
until my teacher was
like, "How about this?
Join Poetry Out Loud."
And I was like, okay.
And then that's when
poetry kind of stuck with me
and I understood what poetry meant.
I looked at it in a different
way, and I really got into it more
than any piece of literature really.
And I spent my most time looking
at poems, learning about poets.
And it was a whole different world.
So I enjoyed it very much.
>> Adrian Matejka:
Wow, that's great.
The idea too of discovering this
new art, it's the oldest art, right?
This is the thing.
It's the oldest form of literature,
and it comes from the tradition
that we're sharing, right?
It's the oral tradition
or hearing a story told,
and it's so wonderful
to embrace that again.
I've had this theory that keeps
not being true, that at some point,
poetry's going to become the
most popular art form ever.
[laughter] Because it's short.
[laughs] And so, you know, I'm
like, okay, there's this thing.
You have it all right there.
It doesn't take three weeks,
like it takes to read a novel.
It's for you.
It gives itself to you in
a short period of time.
But somehow, that just
keeps not being the case.
[laughter] So do you
have a favorite poem,
now that you've spent
all of this time?
>> Iree Mann: You know what?
I've-- my favorite poems right
now, I've spent the most time
with the three poems that I
picked for Poetry Out Loud.
And I think I understand
them so much more
than the other poems
that I've looked at.
And I mean, they've been in
my backpack for the longest.
They've been in my
pocket for the longest.
[laughter] I mean, so those
are my favorite poems.
I think it's the most
thing that I've put my time
into because they've stuck with
me for a very long time now.
And yeah, I would say those are
my favorite poems right now.
[laughs]
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah, those
are good poems to appreciate.
So what were the other two?
>> Iree Mann: So "Break
of Day" by John Donne
and also "American
Smooth" by Rita Dove.
>> Adrian Matejka:
Oh, that's so great.
>> Iree Mann: Yeah, they're all
kind of different from each other.
Yeah.
>> Adrian Matejka: But all
very sonically pleasing, right?
>> Iree Mann: Right, yeah.
>> Adrian Matejka: I think
that that's also the great gift
of this is that there's a-- just
in this list that Iree gave us,
it spans centuries, right?
>> Iree Mann: Yes.
>> Adrian Matejka: And
poetry is so timeless,
you can have John Donne next to
Rita Dove and they don't seem
in opposition in any
really wonderful way.
Nick, what about you?
What's your favorite poem or
your favorite poet right now?
>> Nick Amador: My favorite
poem is "The Love Song
of J. Alfred Prufrock"
by T.S. Eliot.
[laughter]
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah, yeah.
It was -- I think that
was the first poem
that I was just like, wait a minute?
You can do that with language?
I think it's like,
"I should be a pair
of ragged claws scuttling
across the silent seas."
It was over for me once I
started to access it like that.
Do you remember any of the poem?
>> Nick Amador: I do.
Yeah. Just the beginning,
because that's what captured me
right away is "Let us go then,
you and I, when the evening
is spread out across the sky
like a patient etherized
upon a table."
And the first time that
I read those words,
in an English class actually,
I was just like, what?
[laughter] Yeah, it's
the same thing.
Like, you can do that?
And the reason that it's my
favorite poem is because, you know,
it is a really long one, so
there's a lot to digest with it.
But I think that the purpose of
art is storytelling, and really,
really good art can
familiarize the unfamiliar.
But really great art can
defamiliarize the familiar.
You know, like William Carlos
Williams' "Red Wheelbarrow."
That's kind of an infamous
example because I mean,
everybody knows what a wheelbarrow
looks like, but just this --
something about the way that
he writes it, it's like,
do I know what a wheelbarrow is?
[laughter]
But "The Love Song of J.
Alfred Prufrock" takes --
I mean, like, it takes
the idea of life
and just completely
tosses it on its head.
And the way that it
does it is so beautiful.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
And I mean -- that's great.
Do you agree with that, Samara?
That that's what art can do?
>> Samara Huggins: Yeah, I've
never heard it said like that.
That was beautifully put.
But yeah--
>> Adrian Matejka: I saw you nod
and I was like, yeah, we're here,
like [inaudible] [laughter].
So what's your favorite
poem right now?
>> Samara Huggins: One
of my favorite poems,
because I don't think
I have just one.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah, good.
>> Samara Huggins: It's one
that I recited maybe two
years ago at Poetry Out Loud.
What's it?
"A Locked House" by W.D. Snodgrass.
Yeah. It's about this love that kind
of falls apart, but it's told kind
of as a metaphor about a house
that is deteriorating over time.
So--
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah,
that's really wonderful.
Do you remember any of it?
Could you--
>> Samara Huggins: I remember
the last stanza, yeah.
"The house still stands, locked,
as it stood untouched a good
two years after you went.
Some things passed
in the settlement;
some things slipped away.
Enough's left that I
come back sometimes.
The theft and vandalism
were our own.
Maybe we should have known."
>> Adrian Matejka: Wow,
that's really great.
[laughing]
[ Applause ]
So you know, we talked a little bit
about this before we started
the program, and I was like,
okay, who remembers poems?
Because I don't remember any poems.
I remember like a line
here, a line there.
This is what -- my job.
I'm a professor.
I teach poetry every day, and I
still don't know more than a line
or two here or there, right?
[laughter] That's what all
my sheets of notes are for.
But I come up, and like, oh, yeah,
we've got these memorized,
no problem.
[laughter] And so not only --
well, it makes me feel really --
it makes me feel about
where poetry is going to be
and where it's going
to go, continuing.
And we're going to run out of
time here in just a second.
So I left them with --
I want to leave them
with one really tough question,
because I know they can
handle this question.
So I think quite a bit about what
a poem is and what it can do.
But what's the difference,
do you think,
and I'll just start
with you, Samara.
What's the difference
between you know, poetry and,
I don't know, like a YouTube video?
And what can poems do that
YouTube or a photograph
or something like that cannot do?
[laughing]
>> Samara Huggins: One of the
reasons that I love poetry is
because it is so concise.
The poet has a select amount of
words that they decide they can use,
but they have to convey so much
emotion and a story and passion.
And they have to do that in
such a short set of words.
And the structure matters so much.
And I think that in a video,
you can see everything.
Everything is in front
of your eyes at once.
But with poetry, you have to dissect
it and it can mean so much more.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
Yeah, well that is very personal
in that way, so you can own it.
That's great.
Nick, what about you?
Same question.
>> Nick Amador: Yeah, I think
other mediums, like YouTube videos,
you know, like books, like
paintings, they're really good
at taking something abstract
and making it accessible.
And poetry does do
that to an extent,
but what sets poetry apart
is its ability to, you know,
like I said before, defamiliarize
the familiar; take something
that you're used to, writing about
something completely ordinary
and finding the things
that are abstract about it
and creating new worlds
from ordinary experiences.
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah,
that's really wonderful.
>> Iree Mann: Yeah, I think
poetry, it gives you--
you can visualize everything
for yourself.
A video, it's already there for you.
You're watching it, you've already
seen someone else's perspective,
but you can have those, you know,
your own thoughts and
your own imaginary.
And you can make up anything.
It's your own world.
I think that's why it's so intimate.
And also, a photograph,
it's just a moment.
And I think poetry,
it's a whole story.
You know, it's your own world.
You can create it however you want.
And I think that's
the difference for me.
[laughs]
>> Adrian Matejka: Yeah.
No, it's so true.
That's really wonderful.
And that is-- that is great.
I am so proud of the work-- like
I had anything to do with it.
I had nothing to do with the
work the three of you have done.
[laughter] But I'm
so proud of the way
that you represent poetry, right?
There are people in the audience
who actually can help take credit
for maybe supporting a little bit.
But you all did the work
and you learned these poems
and recited them beautifully.
And thank you so much for your work
and for sharing your
poems with us today.
[ Applause ]
Okay. So-- how much time do we have?
Ten minutes?
Okay. So we have just
a little bit of time,
and I wanted to close everything
out with, if this is okay,
asking you each to
recite one last poem?
Can we do that?
She's like, I'm closing in now,
I thought I was ready to go.
[laughter] If you don't want to,
I mean I was hoping
we would have time.
But can we do that?
>> Nick Amador: I don't
think I know one.
>> Adrian Matejka:
Okay, that's okay.
That's all right.
[laughter] So I'll tell you what.
>> Just go.
>> Adrian Matejka: Okay, so --
>> Iree Mann: Yeah, I can.
>> Adrian Matejka: And hey, listen,
this is going to be
the last thing we do.
And thank you all so much
for coming and listening.
We really appreciate it.
>> Iree Mann: Sure.
>> Adrian Matejka: Thank you, Iree.
Sorry to put you on the spot.
>> Iree Mann: Hi, guys, again.
[laughter] "Break of
Day" by John Donne.
'Tis true, 'tis day,
what though it be?
O wilt thou therefore rise from me?
Why should we rise
because 'tis light?
Did we lie down because 'twas night?
Love, which in spite of darkness
brought us hither, should in despite
of light keep us together.
Light hath no tongue, but is all
eye; If it could speak as well
as spy, this were the
worst that it could say,
that being well I fain should
stay, and that I loved my heart
and honour so, that I would not
from him, that had them, go.
Must business thee
from hence remove?
Oh, that's the worst disease of
love, The poor, the foul, the false,
love can admit, but
not the busied man.
He which hath business, and
makes love, doth do such wrong,
as when a married man doth woo.
[ Applause ]
>> Adrian Matejka: Ladies and
gentlemen, your 2017 winners
of Poetry Out Loud, here they are.
Incredible.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit is at loc.gov.